[Music]
miss marvel
is a new kind of superhero but at the
core of all of it her story's so
universal
miss marvel is one of the newer
characters in the marvel comics
and when one comes in that grabs the
world's imagination like this the
questions are
when are we gonna bring miss marvel to
the screen when miss marvel first came
out we had such an incredible reaction
it was so incredibly popular because
everybody could see themselves in her i
never saw a young teenager of color
specifically a pakistani in the comic
book are you kidding
promised you'd be cool i am cool the
casting process
was vast when we discovered iman
we knew that she was kamala khan it was
unanimous decision yeah i can't
comprehend this right now
and then of course we've got a really
incredible team of directors
mira menon and charmino beijing and all
of them
are taking the material and elevating it
so human
it's about a teenager figuring out who
she is and about relationships
family and friendship is at the heart of
the mcu canon
that's what's so exciting about the
story that we're bringing is that we're
going to introduce you to a new family
that's also going to be part of the
wider mcu
[Music]
you